como lo adelantábamos en revista de
prensa vamos entonces a analizar el
papel de internet en la radicalización
de los neonazis y también los seguidores
de la extrema derecha y para ello quiero
darle la bienvenida a nuestro programa
arsenio cuenta el investigador doctoral
sobre radicalización de la extrema
derecha en internet en la escuela
práctica de altos estudios de la ciudad
de parís en francia
arsenio gracias por estar con nosotros
en directo américa de france 24 también
nos acompaña como lo dije anteriormente
rosa pérez base de rosa buenos dias
arsenio queríamos empezar
preguntándole por algunos de los puntos
no que han sido destacados de este
manifiesto atribuido a payton que entró
en el supuesto pues autor de esta
masacre racista perpetrada en buffalo el
pasado sábado no y algunos de los puntos
que se han destacado son las corrientes
de fascismo también la teoría del gran
reemplazo consideramos que son
importantes que es importante saber
identificar estos discursos por lo que
le preguntamos de qué hablamos cuando
nos hace cuando hacemos referencia a
estos términos
hola qué tal muchísimas gracias por la
invitación
bueno realmente cuando estamos
confrontados al manifiesto del
terrorista de búfalo no es exactamente
un texto donde abunden las referencias
bibliográficas las citas autores
etcétera es más un pastiche donde junta
enlaces de internet memes y demás
artículos en prensa no es es propio de
internet y de estos tipos de manifiestos
que no tengan un bagaje teórico muy
profundo
de hecho las menciones que hace al eco
fascismo en su manifiesto
son si cabe' tangenciales él se denomina
co fascista por ejemplo
y luego sí que abunda un poquito más en
la teoría del gran reemplazo que es el
eco fascismo
realmente no podemos hablar de eco
fascismo sin su precursor que es la
ecología radical o la ecología profunda
como se dice en inglés la ecología
que es una corriente de pensamiento y
antimoderna que surge a finales del
siglo 19 y que habla de un
retorno a esa comunión perdida
espiritual entre un pueblo
y la naturaleza esta corriente de
pensamiento
nace en la alemania nazi y finalmente
acabaría influenciando
la parte de la rama la rama política
ecológica del partido del partido nazi y
realmente lo que vemos en el manifiesto
de del terrorista de búfalo es la parte
de ccoo fascista aunque él también
abunda mucho en la cuestión de
el mundo rural la idealización y la
nostalgia de de esta comunidad rural
perdida por la urbanización de las
sociedades etcétera
en lo que hace finalmente es
utilizar los postulados eco fascistas
para finalmente legitimar el genocidio
que es lo que lo que el anuncio ya hacía
el el eco fascismo pensar que la
comunidad blanca en el momento del
nazismo era era la raza aria en este en
este caso sería sería la raza la raza
blanca debe recuperar esta comunión con
su con su entorno natural y para ello es
legítimo acabar con otras especies ahora
arsenio hablemos de otro punto
importante también que queremos tratar
no a raíz de su artículo publicado el
papel que juega entonces en internet de
la radicalización de estos terroristas
de extrema derecha qué papel juega
internet y cómo y por dónde digamos usar
cuál es el punto crítico donde se
promueven estas ideologías de extrema
derecha
claro el problema que plantea internet a
día de hoy es que teorías
falsamente falsamente científicas o de
carácter o de carácter científico como
el eco fascismo el gran reemplazo está
visto que el gran reemplazo a nivel
demográfico no existe que las cifras no
no se sostienen y por ejemplo si alguien
tiene un mínimo de interés en en
cuestiones relacionadas con con la
ecología
sabe que la el mundo rural es tiende a
ser más contaminante que la vida en los
centros urbanos entonces esto es
propaganda método mitología supremacista
que antiguamente estaba confinada a
espacios marginales
donde no se podía acceder fácilmente ni
a estos espacios ni a estos materiales
y así y así ha sido durante mucho tiempo
el problema el problema de internet es
que
[Música]
ha facilitado muchísimo que contenidos
relacionados con discursos supremacistas
que estén disponibles para el público
aquí en francia por ejemplo con el
frente nacional era uno de los partidos
minoritarios y no tenía para nada los
niveles de una intención de voto que
tiene con los que cuenta a día de hoy el
frente nacional fue el primer partido en
abrir su página web porque sabía que así
era más fácil
poder poder
construir ese vínculo con sus electores
y arsenio disculpe que le interrumpa
pero usted habla de también de espacios
inofensivos no donde uno puede dar con
este tipo de discursos sin irlos a
buscar como uno se iría a buscarlos
precisamente en la página pues del
frente nacional que me gustaría
preguntarle por estos espacios
aparentemente a políticos que usted
escribe y que al final son una puerta de
entrada estos discursos de extrema
derecha
si efectivamente ahí me dirigía que es
qué es lo que ocurre a día de hoy en
internet
los discursos extremistas están
ampliamente analizados
hay una cantidad de pseudociencia y de
noticias falsas
muy difícil muy difícil de contrastar y
muy muy abundante entonces
han llegado ya permear en ciertos
espacios
cotidianos que podemos que podemos
frecuentar en las redes sociales
yo en mi caso he escrito y he leído
bastante sobre todo lo relacionado con
el mundo del fitness y el bienestar
personal en internet estas comunidades
que se crean en torno a pues bueno los
hábitos deportivos a la hora de ir al
gimnasio la alimentación etcétera
en un principio son cuentas que parecen
inofensivas páginas en facebook
instagram etcétera
pero que empiezan a bombardear con
contenido en este caso extremista
de forma totalmente
anodina yo no pienso realmente que haya
alguien detrás que tenga intención de
radicalizar a sus a sus seguidores sin
embargo estos estos meme ese contenido
está está aquí y claro es muy fácil que
escriba de puerta de entrada
para un chico que como comentaba en mi
artículo tiene problemas a la hora de
encarar su sexualidad porque esto es
real hay una hay una tendencia muy
fuerte en internet con vídeos con
millones y millones de visitas sobre
dejar la masturbación como controlar tus
impulsos sexuales y cómo esto puede
beneficiarte a la hora de ir al gimnasio
encontrar pareja etcétera esto ya de por
sí no sólo es un discurso masculinista
de de empoderamiento y de
pensamiento masculino sino que puede
rápidamente
desembocar en el rechazo
a todo lo que se ha asociado a la
feminidad asociar lo moderno a lo
femenino las cuestiones electivo y
feministas etcétera y acabar pues
finalmente en discursos como los de
escuque clan cuando decían que la
industria del porno estaba controlada
por los judíos para controlar la tasa de
natalidad de los de las poblaciones
blancas